[Music]
you might have heard of vertex AI but
what is it exactly vertex AI is an
end-to-end ml platform that helps both
developers and data scientists
accelerate the delivery of ml models and
applications to production vertex AI
enables more people to innovate with ML
with low code tools and advanced
capabilities for custom development all
on fully managed infrastructure want to
build a custom model vertex ai's ml
platform helps teams track custom model
development and deployment from feature
engineering to model training to low
latency inference all with Enterprise
security data governance and
availability we can't wait to see what
you build with vertex AI whether you're
a developer looking to add AI to your
application or a data scientist wanting
to build and scale custom ML and
production vertex AI has the tools that
you need